I got an announcement to make I'm gonna
go on an adventure to find myself and
I'm gonna find myself I'm gonna go off
on an adventure heard you the first time
Andy oh hello Vanessa have you seen Seth
you know I just saw in a second ago
hey I'll see you later right watch later
[Music]
Taylor what happened to you a couple
tweakers gently on the bike pack my
barons playing the Alamo tonight he
should come cool I just see you at the
show just tell me what's going on
I met it guys you know what makes me
feel better
that's it I'm getting better reading
stuff going out tonight I'm going the
show tonight Taylor is back I've got a
change
[Music]
party
[Applause]
come on this is being alive Jamison hi
I'm harmony
[Music]
you never get your heart broken struck
Thank You coming Oh hot maverick is this
like all you guys do sit around and talk
about bands nobody cares about that's
why I liked you Jamison you're not like
those guys I'm right here
[Music]
get out of your friend this is not the
plan stop beating yourself up you didn't
do anything wrong
I don't want to get involved and then
find out that you guys have history and
that you're still into him you have all
these plans and dreams for your life and
none of them include and you run your
deadbeat friends and drinking beer or
corn I'm alive I don't think it gets any
better than this
I wish we'd like to slow down
[Music]
[Applause]
what are we doing tonight
[Music]
you